hi in this video I will tell you the
details how transgenic flies are made in
fly genetics so if any often talk about
trans genes and transgenic flies but we
don't have clear idea that how these
transgenic flies have made so here is a
transgenic fly in this transgenic fly
let's say we have expressed our protein
of interest or let's say we have used a
reporter in this fly like a GFP reporter
or let's say we have cloned P element in
this fly or let's say we have cloned a
mutant I am channel in in this flight to
study the properties of that ion channel
but the question is this fly is
transgenic but how this flight was made
how come this fly has this kind of
insertions of this kind of modification
in its genome the trans gene comes the
trans gene means a gene which is not
inherent part of the flight body or
which is something foreign that we have
manipulated and put inside it but how to
make it so we can definitely use a
cloning approach we can clone your gene
of interest into expression vectors in
case of bacteria what we do we give hit
to hit shock and as a result the gene of
interest get in gets transformed into
the bacteria but can we transform fly it
turns out we can turn transform fly we
can clone our gene of interest in
desired vectors and can inject the
desired vectors in the germline of the
fly and in the very early phase of the
development then most of the cells
develop with that particular vector they
develop with that particular construct
that we are injecting and these vectors
are unique before that see here is a
embryo which are aligned in a specific
manner and with this sharp needle
people are going to inject that
particular construct or particular
plasmid that we wanted wanting one to
fly to be to have so here's another big
picture of that so there are two kind of
vector that people use to transform of
like a P element based approach and a
high directed recombination based
approach so in the P element based
transformation people have a vector
where you have gene of interest a
particular marker mostly people use wide
gene and it's free and it is inside a
transposition a transposon based vector
like PUSD also people use a helper
plasmid which codes for transposons and
both of that are basically injected into
the embryonic condition and the embryo
is w- it's negative for that marker so
that's how we can track our particular
protein of interest whether it is
produced or not so we can inject our
construct and look for several
generations and look for these our
desired progeny a progeny which would
have our red eye would make or may
contain that particular PL Mint now see
this is the transgenic fly in other
approach people have used side directed
recombination based approach where
people have at P and AD be cognate
sequences in specific vector and in the
chromosome and they can recombine to
each other and as a result they the
construct could get integrated into the
genome once the Flies are made they're
kept in the stock center like this and
they are properly annotated and there
are multiple stock centers all around
the world in Bloomington in Vienna in
partly they have a lot of stock but they
maintain this transgenic flies and
aspartame and people can order
there for more information go to flybase
then you can get the links for all of
these websites thanks for watching my
video if you like this video give me the
quick thumbs up please subscribe and
don't forget to share thank you